I feel like my job as an actor is to
find the truth in every situation if I'm
not truthful then you see an actor
acting the help many is a compilation
for me of a lot of women my mom my
sisters some teachers I mean there are a
lot of strong women in my life and I'm
grateful for that
Kathryn Stockett the author of the helm
and Tate were childhood friends and I
met her while she was writing the help
and I think she kind of didn't know what
many would be and the day that we met it
was hot in 100 degrees in New Orleans
and I was on a diet which none of those
things are fun she just saw the edge
that I had and filled in those lengths
went many probably having a little more
of an edge than she had anticipated I
got to come up with questions 208 years
later when the book was finished and she
was going on her book tour she asked me
to do some key cities with her and I
read the Abilene and many characters at
her book signings and so I kind of was
loosely associated with it and then I
was asked to do the book on tape but I
think Tate had always known that he
wanted me for many there was a lot that
he had to do you know fighting battles
for me behind the scenes that I didn't
know about but that I know about now but
knowing I'll never get no job again you
have to play the time and now you know
people think that they would react a
certain way but society was more
oppressive than it is now especially for
people of color and people were killed
for much less so
I had to play the reality of the stakes
have you lost your mind
no ma'am but you back to because you
just did
did what while it was you know funny it
was never funny too many it was never
anything that she wanted to get beyond
the two people because she knew had it
gotten out in public it could have met
harm to her family not only harm to
herself so she it was never meant to be
funny it was meant to be a payback that
only the two of them would know about if
he pushed too hard then it becomes a
joke or it becomes a melodrama in either
direction so there's a balance you have
to strike and for me the balance it
comes when you find the truth of
whatever this scene is and whatever the
circumstance of the moment is and the
truth for many and all of the maids was
basically providing a better life for
their children
and gaining civil rights snow person
well I've never done one of those
post-apocalyptic films and definitely
not action and you know to work with
Chris Evans who just is poetic with his
don't work so much so that I had been
working for a few days with a stunt
coordinator and you know kind of bumble
through and I thought I was doing great
and then I saw it and playback like that
looks horrible I remember the site
coordinator telling Chris of hey see
these two guys are gonna they're gonna
confront you're gonna take them out
there this guy's gonna come in from the
back you know do a couple of rounds with
him and then you're gonna finish the
last guy off and then Christa does it
and it was the most beautiful thing
you'd ever seen and I was so mad at I I
said how long have you guys been
rehearsing that he said well no he just
told me what what he wanted and I said
but no how long have you been been
rehearsing it and he said well he just
just you saw you just told me I might
know but how long did you rehearse it
you know and so that's when I realized
that there's so much more to what we do
because I've been a walking talk after
largely and I like being a mop and talk
actor it was very difficult but a lot of
fun but there are a lot of things about
me that I terrified of being hit and so
there was a sequence coming up we go
through a tunnel and we're fighting the
bad guys but then it gets really dark
and I started having a panic attack
because I thought well all the lights
are going to go out and somebody's gonna
hit me for real Chris kind of picked up
on that and I think I just burst into
tears like I'm terrified I'm terrified
that I'm gonna get hit and he was so
sweet that when he got done with hair
makeup he kind of went and you know
relayed to the ADEs and the director
that I might not need to be in the dark
scene where we go in the tunnel and
everybody's hitting everybody I love him
dearly for that because they took me out
of that see proof Alsatian Wanda is a
very real person who lost her son and
it's the first time that I've actually
had to play someone who was still alive
and then to know that she suffered such
a tremendous loss I realized the
responsibility was probably far greater
than any role I'd ever played because
life extended beyond the screen and it
was representative of her son who she no
longer had so I felt like we all had a
responsibility to show the world that
Oscar lived in you know sadly I thought
it would impact things socially like
there would be fewer and fewer Trayvon
Martin's or Oscar Grant's and it seems
like it just things have completely
escalated to a point of no return
he didn't make it I need to see him okay
you can see him but they don't want you
to go into the room or to touch him
because they ruled it a homicide I can't
ever really let want to go because
although I'm not a mom I'm an aunt and I
took the role because every time I think
of my nephew's leaving the house it does
hasn't changed in all these years I get
a wave of panic and I imagine that
that's something that she felt as a
mother and probably still feels with you
know her grandkids so it's not something
that I I have ever been able to let go
of for me I think the difference in the
preparation is that I didn't prepare it
as if it were the horror film I prepared
it like all the other roles that I've
ever done the genre didn't matter to me
it's the character the whole character
that I was creating girls girls guys
want a party like rock stars or what now
I gotta clean the house before my mom
gets some okay maybe next time damn I
don't she got a job yeah I guess I
should work a double since you guys
don't have time for me there's a lot of
pathos with with Sue Ann and then the
other part the part where she kills
people
because that's not a part of my nature I
had to make that more comedic in my mind
maybe not in the actual execution of the
role but I had to make that funny in my
mind because you know torturing people
is you know there's no way to justify it
and you can't play a character
effectively that you judge
liar I don't relish the idea of having
blood all over me or you know some crazy
rig that they have to do i I was glad
that I wasn't on that side of it
truth be told papi
she got caught up with the idea that
this young man from a very affluent
family she was really hung up on that
and and thought you know will he get a
fair trial and will he get off because
he's from an affluent family and all of
that led to great fame for her because
you know she helped with all her
articles to shape the mind of the public
is there an innocent man in prison and
did I need that charge it's easy to draw
on the social norms now the canceled
culture when Papi's career is on the
Ascension there wasn't the social media
channels and she basically was when
people actually still read the newspaper
still watched the news and listening to
podcasts and and you know talking to
Sarah caning aloud you know space for
for podcasts and in general to help
shape papí hidden figures when I heard
about the premise of this film of hidden
figures I thought it was a historical
fiction the help was historical fiction
and I thought surely we would have known
if all these women black women or so
integral to the space race I mean this
come on it's definite fiction right so
to find out that it was actually true
that there's so many women whose names I
mean don't
what the hell are you doing you can't be
in here
for you I'm with the West computing
group
Dorothy Bond sir well this is a very
delicate piece of equipment I'm sorry
sir I'm just trying to be helpful
uh-huh Phil we've got numbers number see
what's your name again
Dorothy Fong I read a lot about Dorothy
she actually was one of the most
brilliant scientific minds and she's
credited with so much at NASA
she's very prolific in their materials
looks like how can these names be so
prolific with this institution in the
world not know about her but yeah I've
read a lot about Dorothy and did a lot
of research into her life I don't ever
want to be a part of anything that has
any hidden figures you know you want to
give praise or praises do and you want
to acknowledge everyone on the team
because of stuff that we take for
granted you know maybe weren't allowed
that luxury they were taking for granted
the shape of water
I've watched everything Guillermo has
directed I'm everything before I knew
him I was a fan because he loves
creatures and things and I am also
fascinated by creatures and things so
when I met with him it was supposed to
be like a little coffee and you know an
introduction and we said we talked for
like three hours he never mentioned the
script and he talked about everything
politics food antiques and both have a
love for antiques and then at the end of
that three hour meeting he said oh I
wrote this part specifically for you I'd
love to know what you think it was like
okay so I raced home and I read the
first page and everything happens under
water and I emailed him to say I'm in
I've only read the first page but I'm in
I didn't care how big or how small my
character was the fact that he was doing
that first scene underwater I knew I was
in capable hands cuz it's Guillermo
that's good
Jenna
looking like you don't know anything
lord help me if they ask me if I do I'm
not a good liar except de Prost it takes
a lot less people married I knew that he
was creating something this beautiful
fairytale and I just wanted to be a part
of it and an Oscar nomination for
working with the director and cast and
crew people that you admire so much I
definitely fell into a pot of jam and
who doesn't love Jam
[Music]